♪ ♪
>> Sean: IT APPEARS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF HIATUS IN HIS
CRITICISM OF ROBERT MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED I'M
HEADING TO CANADA FOR G7 FOR
TALKS THAT WILL MOSTLY CENTER
ON THE LONG-TIME UNFAIR TRADE
PRACTICES AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES.
FROM THERE I GO TO SINGAPORE
AND TALKS WITH NORTH KOREA.
ON THE DENUCLEARIZATION.
OF COURSE, OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
WON'T BE TALKING ABOUT THE
RUSSIA WITCH HUNT HOAX FOR A
WHILE.
HERE WITH REACTION TO THE
UPCOMING I.G. REPORT.
AND MUELLER'S ONGOING WITCH
HUNT, MARK PENN.
ATTORNEY VICTORIA TUENSING.
DAVID LIMBAUGH.
ALL I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT DAVID,
VICTORIA AND EVERYBODY, I HAVE
THE BEST LAWYERS IN THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE DONE LEGAL WORK FOR
ME.
BUT IF I DON'T SAY IT EVERY
TIME THE LEFT WING MEDIA HAS
WHAT HEART ATTACK OVER
NOTHING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL.
DAVID, I'LL START WITH YOU.
WE KNOW CRIMES ARE COMMITTED
HERE.
NOW THE PRESIDENT IS MOVING IN
TO REAL OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SOME SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT
WILL IMPACT THE ENTIRE WORLD.
OUR KIDS AND GRAND KIDS.
BUT THE WITCH HUNT CONTINUES.
SMART OF HIM TO LET IT GO FOR
A WHILE?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT THE
MEDIA WILL NEVER LET IT GO.
TRUMP CAN RE-ENTER THE FRAY
ANY TIME HE WANTS TO.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE UNDER
ESTIMATED TRUMP ON FOREIGN
POLICY AND TREAT HIM AS A
COMIC BOOK PLAYER.
I ADMIT I'M SURPRISED THAT HE
IS AS GOOD AS HE IS.
ON FOREIGN POLICY, I MEAN.
WHEN HE MADE HIS COMMENT ABOUT
NOT PREPARING WHAT HE MEANT IS
HE HAS NEGOTIATED ALL HIS
LIFE.
HE DIDN'T PINE HE -- DIDN'T
MEAN HE WOULDN'T BONE UP ON
SOUTH KOREA, NORTH KOREA AND
U.S. HISTORY.
>> Sean: HE SAID HE HAS BEEN
PREPARING HIS WHOLE LIFE.
>> LOOK AT THE WAY HE IS A
REALIST.
HE IS WILLING TO WALK AWAY.
LOOK HOW CALM HE IS.
HE BELITTLES ROCKET MAN WHEN
HE KNOWS TO BUT OTHERWISE HE
IS SERIOUS AND HE ENTICED HIM.
I THINK TRUMP IS SEEN AS A
CAPITALIST.
KIM JONG UN IS IN WORST SHAPE
THAN HE HAS EVER BEEN IN.
OF CHINA AND UNITED STATES
HELP HIM REBUILD HIS DARK
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: HAS HE STARTED TO
PURGE SOME OF THE OLD
HOLDOVERS THAT, YOU KNOW,
WOULD BE SO RIGID AGAINST
CHANGE?
LET ME GO TO THE I.G. REPORT.
ANOTHER BIG STORY.
YOU ARE A LONG-TIME CLINTON
POLLSTER, MARK.
YOU HAVE BEEN THERE.
YOU HAVE BEEN CRITICAL.
DAVID AND VICTORIA WILL TELL
YOU THAT HILLARY VIOLATED
MULTIPLE LAWS.
SERVER, LITERALLY HAVING TOP
SECRET CLASSIFIED SPECIAL
ACCESS PROGRAM INFORMATION ON
AN MISHANDLED IT, DESTROYED
IT, COVERED IT UP, OBSTRUCTED
AFTER SUBPOENA DELETIONS AND
ALL OF THAT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
WE KNOW THE TRUTH THAT IS WHAT
THE I.G. SHOULD SAY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT IT
HAVING WORKED FOR THEM SO
LONG?
>> YOU KNOW, FIRST, LET ME SAY
ON THE EVE OF THE SUMMITS.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE
DISCIPLINE WITH THE TWITTER
ACCOUNT AND I HOPE GIULIANI
HAS DISCIPLINE AND SCHUMER AND
PELOSI HAS DISCIPLINE SO WE AS
A COUNTRY SPEAK WITH ONE VOICE
AGAINST A DICTATOR FOR
SOMETHING THAT CAN AFFECT ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN FOR A COUPLE
OF DAYS.
I THINK IT WILL REQUIRE THAT
KIND OF DISCIPLINE.
NOW WHEN THIS REPORT COMES OUT
A COUPLE OF DAYS LATER, THIS
REPORT IS ACTUALLY NOT GOING
TO BE ABOUT THE CLINTONS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHETHER THE
CLINTON --
>> Sean: PARTLY IT IS.
HOW WAS IT HANDLED OR
MISHANDLED?
>> YES BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
WHETHER THE F.B.I. DID ITS JOB
PROPERLY OR IMPROPERLY?
THAT IS WHAT THE REPORT IS
ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
AWAY FROM THIS BECAUSE THAT
CARRY OUT THAT INVESTIGATION
FAIRLY, WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
THAT THEY CARRIED OUT THE
TRUMP RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
FAIRLY?
>> Sean: YOU HAVE BEEN
OUTSPOKEN AND CRITICAL AS A
DEMOCRAT.
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU CREDIT.
THIS IS BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT CAN'T STAND.
>> I THINK OUR CONSTITUTION IS
BEING STEPPED ON, SEAN.
AND WE REALLY HAVE TO BE ON
GUARD HERE THAT PRESIDENTS CAN
DO THEIR JOB WITHOUT THE
CONSTANT THREAT OF AN
INVESTIGATIONS FOR EVERYBODY
IN THEIR ADMINISTRATION, FOR
EVERYBODY IN A CAMPAIGN THAT
GO ON WITHOUT END.
I CAN TELL YOU I'VE BEEN
THERE.
I WAS WITH THE PRESIDENT IN
1998.
IT DID NOT HELP THE COUNTRY WE
WASTED A YEAR ON THAT.
WASTED A YEAR ON THIS.
WE SHOULDN'T BE WASTING
ANOTHER YEAR IN THE ABSENCE OF
REALLY COMPELLING EVIDENCE
WHICH WE HAVE NOT BEEN IN ANY
RESPECT SEEN.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO YOU,
VICTORIA.
I THINK THE EVIDENCE IS
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
BUT MARK IS RIGHT, IT WILL
DEAL MOSTLY WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THERE ARE UNDERLYING
CRIMES.
THE FACTS ARE NOT IN DISPUTE.
JAMES COMEY LAID THEM OUT TWO
DAYS AFTER THEY EXONERATED
HILLARY.
HOW SHOULD THIS BE HANDLED IF
THE CRIMES WERE COMMITTED AN
THE INVESTIGATION WAS RIGGED?
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I'M
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THIS TRUMP COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS JUST A MOCKERY.
HOW THE REPUBLICANS ARE
FAILING US.
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
I HAVE SOME VERY GOOD SOURCES.
LET ME TELL YOU THAT SPEAKER
RYAN AND TREY GOWDY DECIDED IT
WAS NOT IN THE MODERATE, THE
REPUBLICAN MODERATES' INTEREST
FOR THE FALL ELECTION, IT WAS
BAD POLITICS TO BE AT ODDS
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ON THE 2016
ELECTION.
SO THEY DECIDED THEY WERE
GOING TO TAMP IT DOWN.
WHEN TREY GOWDY CAME ON FOX
AND SAID WELL, WHEN THE F.B.I.
HEARD WHAT THEY HEARD, THEY
DID EXACTLY WHAT WE ALL HOPED
THEY WOULD DO.
NO, HE WAS TAMPING IT DOWN.
AND THEY WERE NOT DOING WHAT
WE HOPE THEY WOULD DO, BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT FOLLOW PROTOCOL.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO GO TO THE
AMERICAN AND SAY DO YOU KNOW
YOU ARE BEING TARGETED BY THE
RUSSIANS?
NOT ONLY THAT.
TREY GOWDY SAID THAT WITH ANY
OTHER KNOWLEDGE WHATSOEVER.
DO YOU KNOW WHY, SEAN?
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Sean: YEAH.
>> AND GUESS WHAT HAPPENED?
YESTERDAY, THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE DELIVERED, THE DOCUMENTS
BY D.O.J.
THEY GOT SNOOKERED BECAUSE THE
D.O.J. BACKED OFF.
THEY BACKED OFF.
WHY DID THEY DO IT?
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PUT THEM
OUT NEXT WEEK WHEN WE HAVE THE
NOKO --
>> Sean: PUT IT ON TUESDAY.
>> THEY WANT IT BURIED WITH
THE I.G. REPORT.
THE REPUBLICANS GOT SNOOKERED
BEING NICE.
JUST LIKE YOU SAID.
YOU CAN'T SUCK UP TO YOUR